le salon de l'UTO officiellement
inauguré ce matin par François mitteran
le chef de l'État qui a fait le tour des
stands comparant les vedettes de ce 73e
salon de Paris un salon d'ailleurs fort
bien fréquenté aujourd'hui c'est un
reportage d'Olivier Lerner et de y Barb
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît le plus dans
une voiture la vitesse le confort ou la
beauté c'est difficile à dire la vitesse
je suis pas du tout un conducteur lent
mais qu même raisonnable pas pour la
vitesse surtout pour la tenue de route
c'est pour marcher d'une façon régulière
faire joujou avec les plus belles totos
du monde poser des questions comme à la
télé à tonton François ou à papa George
un scoop pour Barbara à rendre jalou
tous les
journalistesce voulez voir les
moteursz voir il y a des moteurs il y en
a partout des présidents aussi et George
le papa de la régie Rena enenvoyer ses
chers petits à l'école le président le
vrai allait immanquablement passer par
là le moteur F fin la technologie les
nouveaux modèles bref c'était autour de
François mitiran de poser les vraies
questions et à George B d'y répondre
chez Peugeot et Citroën encore un
président Jacques CALV et là encore le
chef de l'État a engagé la discussion
sur l'emploi dans l'entreprise l'avenir
de la 205 Turbo mais c'est surtout la
dernière née de la gamme Citroën que
souhaitait essayer François mitter si
son emploi du temps le lui permet il ira
peut-être chercher la petite Barbara à
la sortie de l'école avec cette superbe
AX cabriolet modèle non commercialisé
barbara a sûrement encore beaucoup de
questions à lui
poser l'industrie automob